[Applause]
meghan markle and prince harry are
making their way
to netflix yeah it's good to be home the
duke and duchess of sussex have signed a
major production deal with the streaming
service e.t has learned i
never thought my life would be that
awesome while the former suit star has
no current plans to return to acting
meghan will lend her hand as a producer
and there's no doubt she has her work
cut out for her
the sussex's netflix deal includes
producing films
and series we're talking scripted series
docu-series documentaries
features and even children's programming
that's
magic we're a fantastic team we know we
are what's more
megan and harry are planning to produce
content about stories and
issues they hold near and dear they'll
even highlight
issues that their non-profit archwell is
focused on
already in the works a nature
docu-series and an
animated series that celebrates
inspiring women there is a lot of
speculation that they're pitching tv
programs about civil rights about
feminism about black lives matter
of course the sussexes are also
committed to promoting diversity at
their production company
this includes highlighting diverse
voices and being committed to diverse
hiring practices
you can either train people to be cruel
or you can train people to be kind
and it's really that simple most
recently harry flexed
his producing muscles teaming up with
filmmakers and appearing in the netflix
documentary
rising phoenix there isn't anything else
in the world
that can bring you back from the darkest
places than sport
and of course megan lent her voice to
the heartwarming disney plus documentary
elephant earlier this year i hope that
when people
see this film they realize how connected
we all are
and if we had more of an awareness about
the obstacles we're facing
i think we take care of each other this
planet and animals
in a very different way that's why it's
really important for me to be able to
help tell that story
the couple is looking forward to being
able to share more of these stories with
their new deal
in a statement the couple explains quote
our lives both
independent of each other and as a
couple have allowed us to understand
the power of the human spirit of courage
resilience and the need for connection
through our work with diverse
communities and their environments
to shining a light on people and causes
around the world
our focus will be on creating content
that informs
but also gives hope this is the world
that
you guys are going to inherit i'm saying
you guys because i'm predicting that
most of you and your
and are in your late 20s and they went
on to detail how being
new parents to one-year-old archie has
highlighted the importance of making
inspirational family programming the
couple also stressed the importance
of telling powerful stories through a
truthful and relatable lens
if things are fair that that completely
tracks for me if things are fair if i do
something wrong be the first one to go
oh my gosh i'm so sorry i would never do
that but when people are saying
things that are just untrue i don't know
anybody in the world that would
feel like that's okay and netflix co-ceo
and chief content officer
ted sarandos had this to say quote
harry and megan have inspired millions
of people all around the world with
their authenticity
optimism and leadership we're incredibly
proud they have chosen
netflix as their creative home and are
excited about telling stories with them
that can help build resilience and
increase understanding for audiences
everywhere
we are taking a leap of faith so thank
you for giving me the courage
to take this next step megan and harry
stepped back as senior royals at
the end of march a decision which was
made in part
to allow them financial freedom